these devices are computers whether it's
an Android phone an iOS phone or
whatever inside is a processor which is
a computer the instruction set which is
the iOS and all the applications that
you run and the memory in which you
store your data you need a hardware
engineer and a software engineer the
hardware engineer takes the phone apart
and it copies the instruction set which
is the iOS and applications and your
memory and then you run a piece of of
program called a dis assembler which
takes all the ones and zeros and gives
you readable instructions then the coder
sits down and he reads through and what
he's looking for is the first access to
the keypad because that's the first
thing you're doing when you input your
pad it'll take half an hour when you see
that then he reads the instructions for
where In memory this secret code is
stored it is that trivial a half an hour
the FBI knows this apple knows this and
this is not an indictment of Apple